how did you identify areas of the  business that you needed to bring  somebody in on  anything that you can replicate or  anything that's repetitive is probably  the easiest thing to sort of outsource  for you it's probably easy to get like a  finance person in because you know if  the finances is slightly off it's not  going to break your heart whereas from a  creative perspective it'll break your  heart if something  isn't exactly yeah and you thought it  would be it's tricky to find people  because if you find people who are super  smart and super motivated they're either  extremely pricey  or they're just really hard to find